et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Éric verte bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous députés de l'Oise membre de la
majorité présidentielle on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour un interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Christelle Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
bonjour Yann bonjour
présenté hier sa réforme des retraites
il y a plusieurs points on va revenir en
détail sur ces points mais il y a
notamment le report de l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ans et non plus 65 le
gouvernement a cédé aux républicain je
crois pas du tout le gouvernement enfin
le président de la République d'ailleurs
lui-même avait annoncé 65 et il finit ce
sera 64 mais à partir du moment où il
annonçait également une grande phase de
concertation intense longue c'était long
tout le monde a parlé avec tout le monde
beaucoup donc c'est non je dis pas ça
mais non parce que maintenant on est
dans l'action dans la décision mais
c'était sans doute nécessaire il faut
aussi à un moment donné
entendre ce qui peut être dit et on peut
entendre ce qui est peut-être dit à
partir du moment où ça ne vient pas
éroder affaiblir l'efficacité de la de
la réforme elle-même il y a aucun
gouvernement qui ne fait une réforme des
retraites notamment d'augmentation de
l'âge qui est donc par principe très
impopulaire qu'il fait par plaisir ou
par ou par idéologie ça ça n'existe pas
c'est extrêmement difficile donc il faut
se donner tous les moyens de convaincre
et donc de parler
plus loin et vous êtes un peu revenus en
arrière aussi
vraiment d'âge contrairement à ce qui
était le cas et puis le président de la
République surtout l'avait pas dit dans
son dans sa campagne présidentielle
Nicolas Sarkozy n'avait pas dit donc il
fallait expliquer en plus pourquoi on
faisait quelque chose qui avait pas dit
alors que Emmanuel Macron avait
clairement dit après on est dans des
modalités de construction de la réforme
mais il faut pas toucher à l'efficacité
de la réforme et avec 64 ans c'est à
dire un décalage de deux ans ce qui
était le cas alors ce que j'ai moi-même
présenté une réforme des retraites
d'augmentation d'âge nous avons décalé
de deux ans moi je souhaitais 3 à
l'époque bah oui effectivement il y a eu
trois prévus et en fait ces deux mais
ces deux permettent d'équilibrer le
système à partir de 2030 et c'était
l'objectif prévu et permet aussi
financièrement de financer les mesures
supplémentaires de d'amélioration de la
de la justice sociale à l'intérieur du
système de retraite on en parlera sans
doute des carrières longues etc la
pénibilité
est-ce que c'était vraiment nécessaire
Laurent Berger dit le déficit finalement
il aurait été Epsilon dans les parties
de gauche aujourd'hui disent elle
n'était pas nécessaire cette réforme des
retraites
comment comment expliquer vous qui est
une lecture par exemple du rapport du
corps aussi différente entre vous et les
représentants de la gauche c'est pas un
truc que vous lisez le soir avant de
vous coucher ou alors ou alors vous vous
endormez donc c'est des rapports
compliqués techniques avec beaucoup de
scénarios on peut en tirer un peu ce
qu'on parfois ce qu'on ce qu'on veut
mais il y a quand même une constante
dans les rapports du corps c'est qu'il y
a des déficits sur les vins ou 25
prochaines années vont se faire à partir
de l'année prochaine nous on peut pas
c'est on peut toujours tourner autour du
sujet vous savez à un moment donné quand
on parle de retraite c'est d'abord une
question d'âge quand vous parlez de
retraite à quelqu'un dans la rue il vous
pense tout de suite à l'âge c'est comme
si vous parliez de mariage sans parler
d'amour c'est quand vous parlez de
retraite vous parlez d'âge c'est parce
que c'est la clé du du point et on
on ne peut pas
rééquilibrer un système de retraite
uniquement par la baisse des pensions
enfin bon courage à celui qui fera la
baisse des pensions mais ce qui avait
besoin et au futur retraités vous aurez
de moins en moins de pension donc moins
en moins de pouvoir d'achat au moment où
vous prendrez votre retraite sachant
qu'on fasse de plus en plus du temps à
la retraite de déficit sur 300 milliards
c'est pas grave
on considérable c'est considérable c'est
parce qu'on a perdu tout repère la crise
économique la crise covid l'inflation
nous font perdre tout repère 10
milliards c'est considérable 10
milliards c'est beaucoup plus que que le
budget de la plupart des ministères
français donc c'est évidemment
considérable et c'est tous les ans et
c'est 10 qui monte qui monte jusqu'à 40
milliards
dans des conditions d'ailleurs en plus
où on considère qu'il y a moins de
chômage et de la productivité donc dans
des conditions qui sont plutôt plutôt
ambitieuses c'est un monde jusqu'à 30 40
milliards d'euros autant qu'on puisse le
calculer dans les années 2050 donc c'est
un cycle infernal et vous ne pouvez vous
en sortir que si vous réformer
structurellement le système et le
système pour le réformer l'efficacité
c'est de faire ce qu'on fait tous les
autres pays c'est un moment donné
d'augmenter l'âge de départ à la
retraite et évidemment de donner la
possibilité à celles et ceux qui ne
peuvent pas qui ne peuvent pas affronter
cette augmentation de l'âge pour des
raisons physiques pour un certain nombre
de raisons de partir un peu plus tôt et
c'est ce qui est faible plutôt bien fait
dans le cas de cette retraite puisque
les conditions de départ des personnes
qui sont en carrière dites longues sont
considérablement améliorés
qui devront travailler plus de 43
annuités parce que ils sont partis tôt
avant 20 ans vous pouvez partir avant 64
ans mais après 20 ans est-ce qu'il y a
des gens qui seront obligés de faire
plus de 43 annuités
la réforme elle est hybride vous avez à
la fois mesures d'âge deux ans
d'augmentation de l'âge de départ et on
commencera à de départ très vite à
partir du 1er septembre 2023 et puis en
même temps une accélération de ce qu'on
appelle le Touraine donc une
accélération de l'augmentation de la
durée de cotisation d'ailleurs le toit
elle-même madame Touraine socialiste
avait au fond prolongé le dispositif de
François Fillon à l'époque sur la durée
de cotisation donc on a les deux points
les deux systèmes vous faites la durée
de cotisation et l'âge pourquoi parce
que vous pouvez rentrer tôt sur le
marché du travail parce que vous avez
pas fait d'études parce que la vie a
fait que vous n'avez pas pu ou pas voulu
faire d'études et vous êtes rentrés à 20
ans à 21 ans c'est logique de travailler
si vous faites pas d'études il y a pas
il y a rien d'exceptionnel là-dedans et
donc vous pouvez partir vous avez un âge
d'ouverture des droits et puis qui
pénalise au fond ceux qui ont commencé
travailler un peu plus tard parce qu'ils
avaient ils ont fait de longues études
comme d'ailleurs la plupart des pays
veulent plus de compétences plus de
formation donc c'est pas et donc les
deux les deux jouent ensemble et donc
faut bien regarder
oui mais à un moment donné vous pouvez
aussi vous devez aussi travailler plus
longtemps parce que vous n'avez pas tout
votre trimestre et vous n'avez pas tout
votre email donc vous ne partez pas à
l'âge de 62 ans aujourd'hui beaucoup de
personnes ne partent pas à l'âge de 62
ans donc beaucoup donc il y a aussi des
personnes qui partent avec un peu plus
de trimestre donc c'est c'est très
important ce qui est fondamental là
dedans c'est que quand on combine les
deux mesures on arrive à éponger le
déficit dès l'année 2030 donc on rajoute
à peu près 17 milliards d'euros dans
dans le système des retraites venant du
système de retraite donc il y a un
autofinancement du système de retraite
ce qui permet de financer à peu près 5
milliards d'euros puisque le déficit de
l'ordre de de 12 13 milliards d'euros 4
à 5 milliards d'euros de mesure
supplémentaires le fait que et sachez
aussi également que quand on dit que on
augmente l'âge de la retraite beaucoup
beaucoup de nos compatriotes qui partent
bien avant l'âge de la retraite c'est
40% de personnes qui liquides leur
pension qui partent avant l'âge
ouverture des droits aujourd'hui 40% la
plupart c'est par le biais du système de
carrière longue et puis une grande
partie aussi par le biais de tous les
disponibles de pénibilité d'invalidité
d'incapacité donc c'est c'est
considérable et en même temps aussi la
plupart des gens qui qui partent ils
sont en emploi 70% des gens qui liquides
leur pension sont à ce moment-là sont en
emploi donc on a une vision je pense
très saine de notre système et cette
longue chaîne de solidarité entre les
générations c'est magnifique le système
para répartition c'est quand on regarde
dans notre modèle social c'est
magnifique c'est pas de la comptabilité
je vais tant vous le dire d'un système
de de justice entre nos différentes
générations on se passe le témoin au
fond à un moment donné j'ai payé pour
toi
tu paieras pour moi donc c'est assez
extraordinaire si vous le mettez en
déficit chronique alors à ce moment-là
il n'existe plus ce système et ça veut
dire que c'est la mise en cause du
système par répartition lui-même vous
parlez de solidarité François bayrouleur
d'une interview il y a quelques jours
dit cette réforme n'est pas tout à fait
juste il faudrait en demande beaucoup
d'efforts aux salariés il faudrait aussi
demander une contribution aux
entreprises qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
cette de cette proposition lui dit une
augmentation des cotisations patronales
par exemple est-ce que vous y êtes
favorable non pas du tout pas du tout on
est déjà un pays on est le pays qui taxe
le plus dans le CDE enfin de regarder
toutes les études on est le pays qui
taxe le plus elle est prélèvements
obligatoires sont les plus élevés les
prélèvements obligatoires des
entreprises sont très élevées c'est la
compétitivité du pays et et
si les entreprises sont pas compétitives
il y a pas d'employés il y a pas de
pouvoir d'achat on peut oublier tout ça
chacun doit produire des efforts je
comprends pas l'idée d'évitement des
sujets difficiles il y a un moment donné
l'intérêt général quand vous êtes au
gouvernement vous devez affronter la
réalité et pas vous bercer d'une douche
illusion
je dis que le cœur du système c'est
quand même à un moment donné de parler
des vrais sujets c'est à dire l'âge etc
vous pouvez toujours augmenter les
impôts c'est une réponse classique mais
je pense que même François bayraud quand
il est à Pau et qu'il a des difficultés
il augmente pas tout de suite les impôts
quoi ils regardent quelle est la vérité
des choses donc c'est déjà 28%
les cotisations les cotisations
employeurs et salariés c'est 28% de la
part de 10%
cette réforme semble injuste donc il
faut apporter quelque chose une
contrepartie
à la tête l'injustice et la justice et
il faut mettre des fêtes est-ce que
c'est injuste ou pas il y a des fêtes on
regarde c'est une réforme parfaitement
juste elle protège le modèle par
répartition qui qui est la protection du
modèle par répartition c'est c'est la
première des justices
d'une réforme des retraites le fait de
pouvoir autofinancer d'une certaine
manière le régime de retraite de ne pas
des marchés financiers pour payer votre
propre retraite c'est et le fait aussi
de ne pas faire des petites efforts au
fur et à mesure en modifiant de façon un
peu sournoise un peu invisible en
baissant la valeur du point lorsqu'on
est des régimes des régimes
complémentaires sans trop le dire du
point de liquidation de votre pension
tout d'un coup vous retrouvez avec moi
en décalant la flèche si on etc toutes
ces petites réformes qui conduisent à
aménager les choses au fond elles
aboutissent une chose c'est la baisse
chronique du niveau de retraite
donc si on veut conserver un bon niveau
de retraite on a besoin d'augmenter un
moment donné l'âge de l'article veut
proposer un amendement allant dans ce
sens vous ne le voterez pas
je regarderai tous les amendements et
puis on en discutera mais enfin je note
quand même que François bayraud il
soutient la réforme comme senti comme
François Bayrou avait soutenu la réforme
de 2000 de 2010 donc on peut on peut
bien sûr amener des amener d'autres
solutions les autres solutions elles
marchent pas si vous augmentez que si
vous voulez équilibrer le système par
l'augmentation de par l'augmentation de
des impôts des cotisations sociales
c'est de l'ordre de 4 à 500 euros par an
qu'on demanderait aux Français en plus
si vous demandiez si vous voulez si vous
voulez le faire par le niveau de pension
c'est 6 ou 700 euros que vous recevrez
en moins chaque année vous rendez compte
quand on dit que chacun est à l'euro
près c'est juste insupportable pour les
Français ils ont dit on a qu'à faire un
référendum et puis on verra bien sûr les
gens ils n'ont pas voté pour travailler
plus longtemps comme si on leur dit
est-ce que tu veux augmenter les impôts
ils diront non donc la question elle est
pas de savoir si c'est populaire la
question est de savoir si c'est juste et
si on fait son travail si on fait son
travail de gouvernement c'est-à-dire
qu'on regarde des choses et on essaye de
faire bien c'est pas brutal c'est
progressif c'est pas brutal pas du tout
c'est progressif et on prend en compte
toutes les difficultés de la vie qui à
un moment donné rendre objectivement
objectivement impossible de pouvoir
travailler plus longtemps
Christ déjà parlé du MoDem ici au Sénat
Bruno Retailleau souhaite des pensions
de réversion pour les enfants handicapés
est-ce que vous y êtes favorable faudra
regarder les différents points vous
pouvez avoir 1000 idées mille idées qui
viendront il faut à chaque fois regarder
combien ça coûte faut regarder si c'est
juste parce que parfois vous créez
quelque chose pour les uns et puis vous
percevez qu'à côté c'est pas le cas donc
il y a plein d'idées de cette nature
mais ce qui compte quand même c'est un
moment donné de faire en sorte que notre
système de retraite il souhaite assuré
il soit garanti pendant longtemps s'il
est pas garanti il y a plus de système
retraite à la française c'est le premier
système du modèle social français donc
c'est fondamental et et l'effort qui
sera demandé c'est évidemment un effort
de travailler plus longtemps ne prendra
pas sur le temps de retraite le temps de
retraite il va continuer à augmenter le
temps passé à la retraite va continuer à
augmenter je rappelle quand même parce
que la plupart de nous l'avons
complètement oublié quand François
Mitterrand dans les années 80 après son
élection
fait passer le vote les systèmes le
système les 60 ans à la retraite c'est
parce qu'il était à 65 ans je rappelle
qu'il y a très très longtemps les
Français ils partaient à 65 ans avec une
espérance de vie justement faible on dit
très très loin de cela très loin de cela
hier soir François Ruffin lorsqu'on
meeting dit la réduction du temps de
travail c'est le sens de l'histoire
aujourd'hui on est à contresens est-ce
que vous comprenez cette difficulté dans
l'esprit des Français de sorte de de pas
en arrière en fait François Ruffin il
veut balayer la société dans laquelle on
vit la transformer une sorte de société
trots qui en général se termine
extrêmement mal mais la France elle a
besoin au contraire de plus de travail
la France elle a besoin de seniors au
travail elle a besoin de jeunes au
travail elle a besoin qui est moins de
chômeurs elle a besoin d'une masse de
travail supplémentaire on a besoin de
travailler le débat sur le pouvoir
d'achat il est lié à tout cela aussi le
débat sur le pouvoir d'achat qui est un
bon débat n'est pas un débat sur combien
l'État va me donner pour me garantir
combien j'aurai de prestations sociales
ou de compensation ainsi ou à ça c'est
combien je vais gagner grâce à mon
travail et la quantité de travail
produite en France aujourd'hui est plus
faible que dans bien d'autres pays donc
on a besoin d'une quantité de travail
supplémentaire notamment réduisant le
chômage notamment en partant un peu plus
tard à la retraite notamment en arrivant
un petit peu plus tôt dans sur le marché
du travail justement les Français qui
sont opposés à la réforme aujourd'hui
disent mais on a déjà du mal à trouver
du travail à partir de 55 ans or dans le
projet présenté hier par Elisabeth Borg
il n'y a pas grand chose pour aider les
seigneurs à retrouver du travail ou pour
favoriser l'emploi des seigneurs est-ce
que là c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à
trouver du travail quand on est sur le
marché du travail à 5 ans ou 55 ans
enfin aujourd'hui on trouve quand même
pour une partie surtout mais enfin on
peut trouver
on n'a jamais eu autant d'emplois en
France donc et le chômage est en train
de baisser quoi
des seniors est important enfin le
le nombre de chômeurs seniors et moins
important que le nombre de chômeurs non
seniors le taux d'emploi des seniors a
bien augmenté par la réforme que j'ai
porté il a augmenté jusqu'à 62 et puis
après entre 60 et 64 c'est sûr qu'il y a
beaucoup moins de seniors au travail que
dans la plupart des autres pays donc
donc on doit augmenter le niveau le
niveau du travail mais ça ne prend pas
du travail
hein ça prend pas du travail aux jeunes
de le travail appelle le travail sinon
c'est une vision assez restrictive des
choses où tout le monde s'enferme chez
soi et ils puissent définir coercitives
pour ainsi que des entreprises le
gouvernement non on est heureusement
dans un pays quand même encore à peu
près libre à force de à force de faire
de la coercition partout ça marchera pas
non il faut il faut que le gouvernement
par exemple propose un index propose de
que ce soit ça veut dire que les choses
soient transparentes
mais parce que la sanction c'est c'est
tous ceux qui viendront dans
l'entreprise c'est l'image de
l'entreprise c'est tout ça et des
sanctions par par les consommateurs qui
est bien plus importante que les
sanctions par le gouvernement donc c'est
index qui permettra de regarder si les
seniors ont leur place dans les
entreprises
la même chose que ce qui se passe
d'ailleurs dans l'inégalité aujourd'hui
encore notamment salarial entre les
hommes et les femmes et puis les seniors
il enfin on doit aussi déplacer
l'horizon une réforme des retraites
quand vous déplacez l'âge vous déplacez
l'horizon de votre vie au travail et les
entreprises d'où sont clés pour la
réussite de cette réforme parce que
c'est elle-même qui organise les
conditions de travail vous ne travaillez
pas de la même manière quand vous avez
30 ans ou quand vous en avez 60 pour des
raisons physiques dans la plupart des
métiers pas dans tous les métiers mais
dans la plupart des métiers même dans
tous les métiers au fond ça change on
n'est pas on n'a pas on n'a pas les
mêmes capacités on a une très grosse
expérience mais sans doute le moindre
rapidité physique et parfois un peu de
fatigue intellectuelle ça peut arriver
mais il faut adapter les métiers et donc
il y aura un fond il y a un fond de
pénibilité notamment
certains grands métiers dont on peut
considérer que ils sont pénibles il y
aura un fond qui permettra à la
reconversion si c'est nécessaire de de
la l'adaptation des postes de de travail
donc c'est c'est absolument dans les
années qui viennent
pour la pénibilité il y a des mesures
sur un salaire minimum on en a parlé
sauf que ce matin par exemple quand vous
regardez la presse régionale il y a
juste un chips c'est 64 ans est-ce qu'il
y a pas un problème de pédagogique non
parce que non parce que vous pouvez
toujours être le meilleur pédagogue on
retient quand même deux trois deux trois
choses majeures et c'est le cas il y a
une augmentation de l'âge d'ouverture
des droits comme on dit donc de l'âge où
on vous ou la génération
qui paye de l'âge ou la génération qui
paye votre retraite parce qu'ils sont en
activité accepte de dire je suis
d'accord tu peux y aller tu as fait ton
boulot et maintenant je suis capable de
prendre de te prendre en charge
c'est-à-dire que je suis un actif de te
prendre en charge comme j'espère que mes
enfants me prendront également en charge
et ce système de solidarité il est
absolument absolument fondamental je
rappelle quand même que ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler très tôt il y a
une amélioration considérable du
dispositif de dit de carrière longue
puisque avant c'était moins deux ans
quand on est parti avant 20 ans on
partait grosso modo à 60 ans quand on
avait tous ces trimestres un petit peu
plus d'ailleurs dans un certain nombre
de cas et bien là il y a une
progressivité de ce dispositif de de
carrière longue si vous partez si vous
avez commencé à travailler avant 16 ans
donc c'est très très tôt vous pouvez
partir à 58 ans si vous avez le nombre
de trimestres nécessaires si en général
ils y sont si vous partez avant 18 ans
vous pourrez partir à 60 ans et si vous
pas si vous partez avant 20 ans vous
pourrez partir vous pourrez leur dire
commencer à travailler avant 20 ans vous
pouvez partir à 62 ans donc c'est très
important il y a beaucoup de gens qui
partiront comme il y a aussi beaucoup de
de points très précis qui font des
trimestres avant de compter pas
aujourd'hui ils vont compter si vous
gardez ce type de foyer si vous gardez
si vous avez un congé parental avant les
trimestres n'étaient pas prises en
compte là ils seront prises en compte
lors de la discussion parlementaire
est-ce que la majorité doit se garder
des marges de manœuvre notamment sur ces
deux thématiques la pénibilité et la
carrière longue pour assouplir un peu la
réforme et faire qu'elles soient plus
acceptable par le client
mais ça peut pas être non plus le le
concours de de l'accumulation de mesures
qui qui sont des mesures qui vont au
fond quand même affaiblir l'objectif
initial qui est l'objectif d'équilibre
système justement au Parlement sans
doute voir des ajustements à la marge
mais comme il y en a toujours sinon ça
veut dire un peu de temps à la
discussion parlementaire la discussion
parlementaire évidemment utile donc il
peut y avoir mais le gouvernement il a
une idée
d'amendements vous pensez qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale
ce qui font tout le temps c'est ce que
c'est pas c'est pas trop le
nom parce que de toute façon il y a une
durée limitée d'examens du texte donc
ils peuvent obstruer mais plus
obstruments en discute du texte donc
c'est quand même curieux d'utiliser
c'est quand même curieux non non c'est
pas du tout on utilise pas du tout le
49.3 je il y a un temps limite pour
examiner des des projets de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
puis c'est un projet de loi de
financement des sécurités sociales
puisque dans les minutes qui ont suivi
les annonces d'Élisabeth borne ils c'est
une mobilisation le 19 janvier ils ne
sont jamais apparus aussi uniques depuis
2010 ça doit vous rappeler des choses
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la réaction
elle est classique je note que depuis 12
ans le débat a pas changé il y a plein
de débats qui ont changé les objectifs
peuvent être les mêmes les sujets
peuvent être les mêmes mais parfois les
conditions du débat change c'est
exactement la même position des uns et
des autres
je pense que j'ai fait partie d'un
gouvernement extrêmement responsable qui
a fait ce qu'il devait faire dans ce
dans ce domaine là qui a amené le
système de retraite à l'équilibre
pendant quelques années c'est exactement
ce qu'on avait dit à l'époque le système
il va replonger parce qu'il faut pour
plein de raisons et donc faut
régulièrement revoir les choses il faut
avoir le courage d'être assurant vous là
c'est le cas d'Emmanuel Macron et du
gouvernement et ça j'en suis et ça je
suis d'accord moi je veux pas critiquer
les syndicats ils sont dans leur rôle
ils ont d'autres ils ont d'autres
préoccupations mais quand même l'intérêt
général il est défendu dans la
démocratie par le gouvernement élu par
le par le peuple par le président parle
le président de la République qui se
disent dans la concertation
particulièrement depuis le mois de juin
est-ce que il peut faire cette réforme
sans s'appuyer notamment sur la CFDT qui
est le syndicatif
est parfaitement respectable et très en
colère quand même
[Musique]
cher il était aussi sorti extrêmement
mécontents des des conversations qu'il
avait eu avec moi mais c'est c'est au
fond des
postures c'est à dire combats d'hommes
il y a un moment donné ils ont ils ont
une opinion qui est différente je je ne
partage pas l'opinion de Laurent Berger
mais je voulais dire quand même aussi
que il y a beaucoup de le gouvernement a
mis sur la table un texte assez fin
complet pas avec des normes ouvertures
pour dire on verra bien j'ai c'est très
important aussi de dire ce que ce que
l'on veut il faut être précis il faut
être carré et par exemple sur
l'augmentation des petites pensions dire
que il y a beaucoup de gens quand même
beaucoup de Français qui sont payés et
qui ont des pensions inférieur et il y a
quasiment 2 millions de personnes qui
ont moins de 1000 euros quand ils ont en
même temps tout leur trimestres ils
auront les Français là ils vont passer à
1200 euros
brut c'est-à-dire la CSG 1200 euros brut
ce qui est des portes très importants et
ça c'est bien et ça vous pour les
personnes en activité ça vaut pour les
personnes qui vont prendre la retraite
comme les personnes en activité c'est
dans le texte une agrégation des colères
en cette période d'augmentation des prix
particulièrement des de l'énergie cette
réforme des retraites qui n'est pas
contestée la seule chose que je crains
ou que je craindrai ce serait de paître
à la hauteur des défis qui sont les
nôtres le gouvernement il doit être à la
hauteur des énormes défis qui sont non
pas peu importe je personne ne voit ça
avec plaisir personne n'a envie d'une
pagaille sociale personne n'a envie de
débordement personne personne n'a envie
de se comment on peut avoir envie de ça
c'est pas bon pour le pays mais en même
temps vous pouvez pas laisser filer le
système de retraite moi je demande
beaucoup de réalisme aux uns et aux
autres par rapport à notre pays il faut
faire acte de citoyenneté pas uniquement
d'individualisme
d'Elizabeth borne merci Christelle
Bertrand face au club